- Well being from New York,
did you ever audition for SNL?
Cause you're hilarious.
- I did.
Back in the day, I think it was 1996,
I went to the Montreal Comedy Festival
which was really big for
comedians at the time.
And I remember I had a little heat on me
and people were looking to sign me to
like a development deal.
And then in the middle of that in Montreal
they called and said that
SNL wanted to see you.
And I'd been a huge fan of
SNL growing up, my whole life.
So they said, "Would you
come out and perform?"
And I said, "Sure, no problem,
I'd love to audition."
So I go there to audition
and right before I go on
they say, "What kind of
characters do you have?"
And I was like, "I don't have characters,
I'm a stand up."
And they're like, "Oh okay,
I guess do your stand up."
And I didn't have any characters,
and I stood in a room with a microphone,
no one there, it was pitch black.
I did my whole act, not one laugh.
I didn't hear anybody breathing in there.
- Oh!
- And I bombed so bad, I was the worst.
It was the worst experience ever.
- Oh my gosh.
- And obviously I didn't get it.
I didn't get it, but I
got a development deal.
Because I didn't get it,
I was able to do The King of Queens,
so it actually worked out.
- That's such a great story
for like up and coming comedians as well.
Or like people just really wanting to
achieve their dream.
It's like, I mean, myself included,
they're not all open doors.
Like, you know?
- Right.
- So yeah, you've gotta be
able to like handle that
and build that character.
But I think that's amazing,
cause you're so funny.
Well, they missed out, is
what I'm saying, Kevin.
- That's right.
I appreciate that, Kelly.